look me in the eyes tell me you're not
lying to me see through your disguise
you can't keep on hiding from me it's
the alleged musical feud that keeps on
giving
and this time joshua bassett is up
i was just more like all right let's
gotta face this head-on on thursday the
20 year old singer dropped his second
single this month titled only a matter
of time
but it's only a matter of time
the track comes just a week after
sabrina carpenter released
skin and i'm not asking you
to let it go
outside
[Music]
and weeks following the song that
started all of this
olivia rodrigo's driver's license which
fans theorizes about olivia's reported
relationship and subsequent 2020 split
from her high school musical the musical
the series co-star
and his rumored new romance with sabrina
and you're probably with that blonde
girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything
i'm insecure about of course
none of these romances have been
confirmed but the lyrics to the 20 year
old's new song
seem to hint at relationship drama
time to tell the world that you've been
lying on my name
doing what you want and think you're
gonna get away
while i'll live it up to faith for now
yeah so there's that and then there's
this
and when did you stop being kind
you twisted your words like a knife
well i'm sure
[Music]
when did you stop being so kind why
would you make your pain mine
wow i think one of the things that i've
really learned from
olivia is the um the storytelling aspect
of songwriting and i think that i you
know i'm more of like a
this is how i feel in this moment and
she really does a job of like
telling a story and putting you in that
time and place and i think that
that's been super um inspiring to me and
has definitely influenced
my music but i definitely think that we
we kind of we
you know we grow from each other well on
thursday josh hit up his insta story to
talk about the song and said he actually
wrote it last summer in a moment in time
where social media was bringing a lot of
darkness to my life
he said in part quote we've got to be
much kinder to each other and recognize
there are real people behind the screens
when did you stop being kind
you twisted your words like a knife
well i'm sure that you're hurting inside
why would you make
[Music]